Deadpool is directed by Tim Miller and
stars Ryan Reynolds as Wade Wilson /
Deadpool and we've seen him portray this
character before but gratefully this
movie has also seen him betray this
character before this is a revenge story
and a love story it's about how Wade
Wilson became the Merc with the mouth
Deadpool as we know him there's a
revenge aspect about finding someone he
has a serious serious grudge against and
it's also a love story with the girl
named Vanessa that he meets that changes
his life I don't know a lot about
Deadpool the character but I know enough
and I didn't know what to think going
into this movie because we've already
seen Ryan Reynolds portrayed this
character once in x-men origins
Wolverine and man did that go south
don't so shut the mouth of the Merc with
the mouth please never do that again
ever okay okay it's also coming out in
February and that's not the cinematic
wasteland of January but it is close and
it's a first time director so I had no
idea what to think going in the Deadpool
I was blown away by this movie in every
way I'm serious this movie was freakin
great I loved every minute of this movie
this is coming from somebody who admires
Deadpool and who has liked him in some
of the animated stuff I've seen him in
but doesn't know that much about
Deadpool as a character and now I just
want to read everything there is to know
about this character this movie
surprised me in so many ways now let's
talk about this because it's really easy
to see a comic book film today and just
be like oh my god that was so much fun
there was so much action and so much
cool stuff and I loved every second of
seeing him punch things real hard that's
actually not what I love the most about
Deadpool what I love the most about it
was the script the script is great it's
extremely funny this is one of the
funniest movies I've seen in years
they had no qualms about being
incredibly crude and it's all the better
for it you want to see Deadpool being
like that and you want to see him saying
things that you are thinking but you
just don't say and he says them but the
best aspect of this script and really
the entire film is the timing in which
it came out in relation to all of the
superhero saturation that we're getting
lately because look we like comic-book
movies they're fun it's exciting to see
some of our childhood heroes on screen
duking it out with some of our childhood
villains but look even the most hardcore
comic book fan can tell you that right
now we're oversaturated I mean
everything is a superhero movie
every other month there's a new
superhero movie and they're all very
similar and some of them are really good
and then we have fan for stick Deadpool
knows what world it's in it exists in
today's world and it's fully aware of it
self-aware in every way self referential
constantly he will look at the screen
and break the fourth wall and tell us
something that we're already thinking
about today's state of comic book films
and it was beautiful I loved it this
movie is also very aware of the past
failings of this character and of Ryan
Reynolds has an actor this is scene just
from the amazing opening titles which I
won't spoil I won't ruin it for you but
once you see them you're gonna love it
let's talk about how the film is
directed it is extremely fast-paced
there is not a single dull moment in
Deadpool I was looking for one about
halfway through this movie I was like I
haven't disliked a single thing yet this
is weird this is strange why do I like
this so much this is also good the
action is directed extremely well
there's no shaky cam there is not an
overabundance of cuts everything looks
great and clear and when there is CGI
it's incorporated very well into the
movie like with the character Colossus
but there also isn't an overabundance of
that you can tell they didn't have quite
as much money as other comic book films
and so a lot of this film does feel
refreshingly in camera even though there
is a lot of CGI it's just incorporated
very well and that's what I love about
CGI when you use it as a tool and not as
your entire film it will really help
your movie and Deadpool's the perfect
example of that about the love story
this is where the film could really
falter it could get sappy you could feel
like you weren't invested enough where
you weren't carrying enough or that it
was just some plot device to make you
feel like oh no Deadpool has to do
something because his girlfriend's in
danger the way they handled the love
story was equally as crude as everything
else and I'd loved everything about this
movie this movie surprised the hell out
of me the action was extremely well
handled the acting was good the score
and soundtrack choices were also
extremely good CGI was well incorporated
into in camerawork it was very self
referential it was hilariously funny and
crude and fast paced and absolutely
relentless as an entertaining film Bryan
Reynolds knocked it out of the park as
the character he showed honor to that
character as did the writer and director
the villain played by ed skrein you
might know him for transporter refueled
all I can say is thank goodness he had
this movie up his sleeve because
transport
we filled that didn't work out he works
as a villain for this movie and for this
movie's plot I suppose he could have
been more compelling but for what this
movie needed him to be which was
basically the object of Deadpool's of
revenge he worked great guys this movie
blew me away I honestly cannot believe
that I'm about to say this deadpool gets
an a-plus i gave one a plus last year
Mad Max fury road is Deadpool a
cinematic masterpiece will it be
nominated for all of the Oscars no it
won't but for what this movie needed to
be I thought it was as good as it could
have been and far better not every movie
I'm gonna give that grade to is gonna be
the next Citizen Kane or something this
movie was exactly what it should have
been and I loved every minute of it guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and some really great news something I'm
super excited about is that I actually
have a book coming out thanks to the
cool people at mango media I was able to
get a book published it's the film buffs
bucket list 50 movies from the year 2000
to 2015 I feel you should see it was a
dream come true to be able to write a
book it's been a dream of mine since
elementary school and I was able to
obtain that dream thanks to people like
you guys who have watched my videos for
six years thank you so much I left the
Amazon and Barnes & Noble pre-order
links in the description below if you
feel that you would like to support me
and read this book it would be the
greatest thing ever and I just thank you
so much for years of support thank you
so much you guys have been the best and
to answer a lot of questions I've been
getting about it being in foreign
countries or trying to get it into
chapters right now which is like the
Canadian Barnes and Noble in to the best
of my knowledge it is available on
Amazon in various other countries I
don't know everything for you yet but I
will try to find out guys you are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching and stay tuned later today on
Sunday from my review of samurai cop oh
my gosh that movies it's the movie all
right thank you so much guys you're the
best and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck my eyes